military service definitely has humbled
me as an individual and it also allows
you to be more compassionate with
others my name is vieta wear and I am a
marine and an army veteran when 9911
came I knew that I wanted to serve
myself and so when I turned 17 I
received a waiver from my parents to
enlist in the rltc program at Georgia
Tech I also served and listed in the
Army and then I answered the call in the
government and served there for 6 and
1/2 years I am a con construction
engineer by trade and I function as a
utilities project manager in facilities
the belonging at Yale program allows all
of us an opportunity to network with
each other there are large disparities
with veterans who come home and fight
battles that are silent the struggles
are internal and we need everyone's
support to my fellow veterans on
Veterans Day I encourage you guys to
share your stories with each other and
fellowship in all of our
[Music]
service